ladies and gentlemen
Eli peered out through the bars though
he couldn't touch them a small crowd had
gathered there on the dirt staring their
faces slack almost uninterested Eli
wondered what they were seeing an
emaciated wreck of a man filthy black
hair falling and tattered strips around
a skeletal face a fake charlatan they
seemed unmoved yes sir all the way from
Transylvania Freddy was on a roll
jabbing his cane at a badly painted
backdrop depicting a caped monster
hunched before a crumbling European
Castle Eli was trying to look menacing
but he couldn't help decide that escaped
his lips he'd been born in Illinois and
turned in Arizona
he'd never been to Transylvania in his
life probably couldn't even find it on a
map
he'd never even been outside of the
continental United States cower in fear
mere mortals for here is a creature who
lives only by night lives by feeding on
human prey Freddie punctuated these last
two words with another poke from his
cane
Eli listened to the rise and fall
cadence of the circus owners pitch he
could have hummed along with it like a
familiar song how many nights had he
heard it he lost track the night he'd
emerged from his casket and seen the
cage bars carved with tiny crosses and
festooned with garlic to prevent his
escape seemed a very long time ago
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls the
only living vampire in captivity I give
you
Freddy paused dramatically and swept his
arm toward the cage
the king of the bloodsuckers Lord
Ruthven Eli bared his yellow fangs on
cue as stupid as he'd always assumed
Freddy to be Eli had to admit that the
guy knew his vampire literature
with a flourish the circus owner
produced a limp rat from the folds of a
spangled coat
there was a stirring in the crowd some
of the girls glanced at each other and
crossed their arms scratching nervously
at their elbows no one left and no one
spoke Freddy flicked the rat into the
cage with practiced ease the eyes of the
crowd black pin points followed it's
gray Ark as though it was a ball in a
tennis match
Eli scrambled for it as soon as it
touched the dirt at the bottom of his
cage it was degrading and part of him
grew disgusted at the likely sight of
himself but the growls from his concave
stomach were a powerful motivator
he brought the tiny corpse to his mouth
the rat was dead but it was still warm
Eli wasn't sure how Freddy killed them
but it didn't matter he supposed the
crowd gasps in unison as Eli bit into
the fur gulping the few precious ounces
of blood it was sticky and bitter but he
laughed at it greedily he even squeezed
the rat in his weakened hands trying to
get the last drops nourishment gone he
threw the empty husk into the pile of
straw in the corner when he looked up
through the bars again he could see the
expressions of revolted fascination on
the faces of those assembled he scowled
out at them remembering the days when he
was stronger when he could have taken
down each and every one of those
fidgeting humans with a blow draining
them of blood and leaving their pallid
carcasses to rot and some obscure clump
of shrubbery to be found later by
mystified authorities his hunger reared
up now donned by his pitiful meal a pole
from somewhere deep inside his body a
hunger on the razor edge of agony eli
reached for the bars forgetting himself
for a moment in the heat of his wanting
his hands closed around the metal a
sharp hiss of burning flesh reached his
ears before he felt anything but moments
later the pain came his palms seeming to
shriek of their own accord the fire
racing from them to ignite his entire
body in excruciating conflagration
he snatched his hands away leaving
ragged bits of flesh behind and then
groaned like a wounded animal the people
outside still stared open-mouthed like
fish on dry land but Eli turned his back
on them the show was over next up ladies
and gentlemen if you'll come this way
she's a quarter ton of fun more woman
than you've ever laid your eyes upon
Freddie who was moving on to the next
attraction and Eli retreated into the
shadows curling up in the straw amid the
rat bones and matted fur forms moved
across the front of his cage a few faces
taking one last glimpse at the broken
man the broken creature within he
snarled at the stragglers flashing his
laser red eyes but there was no heart in
it he was no threat to them not in his
present condition he suppose they knew
it for they did not hurry away but just
turn their heads and kept walking
forgetting him already
and the bright promise of a new
spectacle the evening wore on and one by
one the lights on the Midway began to go
dark the shouts and laughter and music
became muted and then ceased completely
giving way to the burr of crickets and
the hollow calls of owls
Eli closed his eyes and smelled the
night closing in around him sniffed at
the essence of the dead rat upon his
fingers as if remembering the perfume of
a departed loved one he was cold and
weak and famished he rolled over on his
back and stared at the ceiling of his
cage wishing he could see the vast
starry sky arching over is open grave
just like it had before when he'd been
free when the night had been his ally
and not his jailer as he was thus
lamenting Eli heard a shuffling in the
dirt outside a rebellious child perhaps
who had stayed behind after the circus
had closed to get one last glimpse
missed Eli no not a child but a woman
are you all right in there
he heard the voice only a couple of
times before but after a moment he
recognized it as Maisie's he dragged
himself up out of the straw mazie stood
in the moonlight the bars dividing her
enormous girth into several pink in
equal sections the shadow that fell at
her feet looked like an enormous black
hole in the earth
her lipstick was smeared her forehead
filmed with sweat Eli knew she'd come
from little Lenny's trailer
he didn't mix with the other freaks or
members of the circus crew but you'd
have to be blind and deaf not to know
about the affair between the fat lady
and the dwarf Eli often tried to picture
the two of them in Lenny's cramped
quarters their disparate bodies nodded
and entwined in the act of love the
incongruity always made his head ache
good evening Maisie you seemed a bit out
of it tonight honey
her sausage fingers curled around the
bars revealing perfectly manicured nails
the light from the waxing moon caught
the gold strands threading through her
bouncing ringlets of hair I've just been
tired that's all he approached her his
bare feet scratching in the dirt he
could clearly hear the throb of her
heart even from several yards away
and he could smell the blood pumping
endlessly through that heart you're
hungry too all bet Maisie said watching
him with her dancing green eyes Freddie
should give you something besides dead
rats to eat like what it isn't as though
he'd bring a human in here it was a more
candid statement than he'd intended and
he thought it might upset her it didn't
seem to I wouldn't put it past him the
creep she snorted then she pressed her
face into the bars smiling with her
smudgy lips you can come closer if you
want I won't bite you she laughed clear
and Belle like in the night air Eli
risked two more steps toward her he had
seen Maisie around of course and newer
to wave too but she'd never come to his
cage after hours before never talked to
him like this she seemed to have no fear
of him not like the others that's a
little better
she said considering his emaciated form
as if it were a particularly delectable
dessert I wanted to give you something
eli shuffled a bit closer suddenly very
nervous what is it you want to give me
Maisie a stake through the heart perhaps
a mouthful of Wolfsbane you have to come
a little closer and then I'll show you
Eli was a prisoner a shell of his former
self but his instincts were still acute
show me first oh you're no fun Lord
breathe then she said with a pout never
taking her eyes from his she pushed back
her pink frilly sleeve and stuck her
jiggling arm through a gap in the bars I
want you to have a drink
Eli's stared down at the arm the peach
fuzz flesh stretched taut over layer
upon layer of fat she looked delicious
but this was Maisie sweet 500-pound
Maisie who had always been friendly
the vampire shook his head I couldn't do
that I'm not saying you can suck me dry
Drac she said with a giggle you can just
have a sip I know you want one I saw the
way you looked at it she was right he
did want to you very badly but Maisie I
he looked into her eyes which were wide
and intense lit with an inner glow I
don't know if I'd be able to stop he
said I wouldn't be able to control
myself oh you wouldn't hurt little
Maisie she purred lashes fluttering I
trust you Maisie you hardly know me
I can't Eli listen all throat Asia sness
dissolved now she was all practicality
I've been watching you for months living
in that filthy cage scrambling around
after Freddy scraps you're starving
honey she blinked as if fighting back
tears I just can't stand to see anyone
like this her arm was beginning to
quiver from being held outstretched for
so long
elie hesitated just for a moment but the
quivering arm decided him he couldn't
resist her anymore
he scurried over and fell down on his
knees taking her flesh and his bony
fingers trying to be gentle but tugging
at it anyway so hard that he saw her
wince his teeth found her skin salty was
drying sweat and he pressed his lips
against her wrist suppressing the urge
to tear into it
there just barely calm he thought his
whole wretched body was shuddering the
first drop of human blood in how long
months had she said glided on to his
tongue and his eyes rolled back into his
head at the ecstasy of it he sucked and
swallowed sucked and swallowed feeling
as though he could never get enough of
it as if he could rip the veins from
their moorings and gulp straight from
them until his belly was stretched and
distended with the feasting heaven it
was sheer heaven Elie he seemed to hear
a voice very far away but he couldn't
heed it wouldn't the warmth of live
blood slithering down his throat was
blotting out all else Elie suddenly his
life-giving sustenance was wrenched away
his fingers grasped at nothing his mouth
gaped wet and bread the sense of loss
threatened to crush him
more please his voice was thick not
tonight
Maisie was clutching her wrist to the
frilly bodice of her dress her fleshy
jewels were pulled into a frown that was
very naughty Elie he lowered his head
I'm sorry
but I told you how it would be I know
you did she peered at her wound then
quickly covered it with her hand again
the Silence of the night was unbroken
but Maisie looked left and right
nonetheless checking for witnesses she
backed away from the bars a few steps
maybe I'll come back in a few nights she
said retreating still farther you can
have more then if you promise to be good
Maisie he didn't want her to go he could
see the fear in her face the fear he'd
planted there she wouldn't come back
good night Elie she waddled off her pink
ballet slippers leaving surprisingly
delicate prints in the dust
at one point she turned and looked at
him over her shoulder and she winked a
secret little gesture that made Eli's
spirit sing perhaps he hadn't frightened
her away after all when she had
disappeared into her own trailer
Eli curled back up in the straw he
wanted to lie there for a while
lie there and feel her blood coursing
through him nourishing him making him
stronger
dear Maisie in a few hours he would have
to crawl into his coffin and close out
the day but after that after that night
again and perhaps another visit perhaps
she really would come back if not
tomorrow night than the next she would
return for the first time in months
Eli managed to smile Maisy came again
two nights later after all the lights
and the other trailers had winked out
the whole troupe had travelled the night
before long rows of caravans across
empty roads but the place they had
settled looked little different than the
last
the fat lady smelled of sweat and sex as
she approached she'd been with the dwarf
again Eli surprised himself by feeling a
twinge of rage at the thought of them
together opposite extremes of human
large and small the dwarf could only
love the voluminous rolls of fat on
Macy's outside after all Eli could
appreciate the entire woman right down
to her red blood cells her beautiful
miles of capillaries she put her arm
through the bars without a word he was
better able to control himself this time
since he wasn't quite so famished he
drank from her other wrist so it's not
to worsen the bruise from his first
attempt she felt some discomfort he
could see it in the lines around her
mouth but she didn't complain Eli kept
eating the rats kept baring his teeth
for the ever-changing packs of dullards
that gathered in every backwater town
they stopped in he even added a few
extra growls to his repertoire jumped at
the bars to frighten the kiddies he grew
stronger each time Maisy visited which
ended up averaging about three times a
week
always after her trysts with little
Lenny a month passed like a dream an Eli
began to look and feel as he had before
his embarrassing capture his body had
filled out his hair had thickened and no
longer looked quite so bedraggled his
flashing red eyes were as bright as a
cat's
mazie came again two nights after
another move thick bracelets encircled
her wrists if any of the others had
noticed her wearing them or wondered
what they concealed Eli hadn't heard of
it after he had drunk a little the fat
lady pulled away and considered him
through the bars I've been thinking she
said
Eli wiped her blood from his lips have
you he tried to keep his tone neutral
but he was afraid of what she was going
to say afraid she was going to
discontinue their rather rewarding
relationship he couldn't bear it if that
was what she was going to say Maisie
she spoke as if she hadn't heard him
you've been getting so much stronger Eli
it's really amazing please don't say it
why not
she goggled at him all I was going to
say was that you should really think
about getting out of here you're a
powerful man she breathed out through
her lips someone like you shouldn't be
caged up like you are forced to perform
for idiots it isn't right so I was
thinking that maybe I could help you
escape somehow the thought of freedom
was a strange one for him and when he
realized he hadn't entertained for quite
some time he had become used to his
situation institutionalized perhaps and
completely dependent on Maisie
he knew that wasn't good knew it
couldn't last forever yet he still felt
a tug of disappointment all the same how
will you help me I'm not sure yet she
said leaning close to the bars stage
whispering like a giant femme fatale in
a film noir
I thought I could steal the keys from
Freddy though I'm not sure where he
keeps them could you get out if I open
the cage Eli steps back and considered
the bars hung with their withering
talismans yes he could probably get past
if the door was opened provided he
didn't touch anything for a second he
wished he could turn into a mist like
they did in the movies but then he
dismissed the fancy I'm sure I could he
said well then I'm not sure when I'll be
able to get the keys but it'll be soon I
promise
and then I'll come and get you after
everyone's asleep I'll even give you a
goodbye sip before I set you free
eli was touched in a way he'd never been
with a human what were they any way but
cattle meat for his kind but his chest
fluttered with impossible tenderness for
Maisie all 500 wonderful pounds of her
thank you he said it was all he could
think of to say there were no words
really to express his gratitude and even
though he still felt a selfish twang of
regret at losing his meal ticket he knew
he couldn't ask more of her she'd done
so much she seemed to understand
everything he'd been thinking her
laughing eyes shined in the moonlight
Sunil I she said hoarsely
then she pressed her fingers to her lips
and blew a kiss through the cage bars
Eli watched her go her thighs wobbling
at rubbing together her ankles swollen
blue could I take her with me when I go
he thought and turned her into a thing
like me I could be with her forever then
lose myself in her ample flesh and
undying loyalty he chuckled to himself
her blood must be making him giddy
she didn't come the next night Eli
hadn't really been expecting her so soon
or so he told himself but the depth of
his despair at her absence alarmed him
he made himself relax she'd said it
wouldn't be right away hadn't she
perhaps it was harder getting the keys
from Freddy than she had anticipated he
had to give the girl a chance the next
night past just as uneventful II and
Eli's spirit sank to a lower point than
he would have thought possible
was it the promise of freedom or simply
the thought of seeing Maisie that gave
him hope her failure to show the reason
those hopes were so cruelly dashed on
the third night he tried to catch her
eye as she stood on the platform at the
end of Freddy's outstretched cane she
preens like a grotesque funhouse mirror
version of a beauty queen clad in her
absurd feminine frills yards and yards a
pink tulle in satin like a froth of cake
frosting he waved surreptitiously
flapping his bony fingers trying not to
draw the attention of the gaping crowd
in front of her she either didn't notice
or was pointedly ignoring him
he considered calling to her such was
his desperation that he didn't care who
heard but then he thought better of it
frustrated he kicked the corpse of
tonight's rat into the corner and sat
down to wait the Midway closed down a
little while afterwards though to eli it
felt as though an eternity had passed he
sat very still in his cage as the night
seeped into his pores he didn't know
what ramshackle town they were in
tonight he lost track of the stunted
trees in the choking weeds and the
sloping foreheads of the circus patrons
all alike in every respect but it didn't
matter really what town they were in the
darkness smelled the same everywhere
he thought he must have dozed because it
seemed only seconds later that the air
was alive with noise his lids snapped
open at first he saw nothing but the
scrubby foliage tossed about in the
breeze but then one by one lights
flicked on in each of the trailers
yellow squares falling upon the dusty
ground the sounds which soon revealed
themselves to be screams reached a
critical pitch two voices harmonized in
a symphony of pain and terror then
abruptly one voice ceased leaving the
other to continue alone soaring to
heights surpassing angels Eli wasn't
sure how he knew but he had no doubt
that the remaining Scream was Maisy's as
to the other the one that had been cut
short whose Lenny's Trudi the torsos he
had no idea and didn't think he cared in
any case only Maisy's agony moved him
the vampire was on his feet and had
crossed his cage to the bars in less
than a moment he couldn't touch the bars
Christ but he longed to grab them pull
them apart with his growing strength rip
them from the cage and fling them hither
and yon like massive yarrow sticks their
pattern and falling predicting his
likely future he thought he might risk
it and grasp the bars in his hands face
contorted in concentration but the metal
burned and tore sending electric
currents coursing up and down his arms
threatening to fry him to Flay him with
fire he shrieked and pulled back adding
his feral cries to the spiraling opera
Maisy's distress he called her name then
called for the others to come out of
hiding to come and help her why didn't
they where was Freddy or Atlas the
strong man
could help her if they would only his
vision was suddenly overwhelmed by what
seemed like acres of heaving white flesh
and copious roles as Mazie nude and
screeching burst from freddy's trailer
like a human wrecking ball her breasts
and legs and stomachs smeared with blood
eli called for her straining his body as
close to the bars as he dared her eyes
were as big as shot puts all pupil and
no white but he couldn't tell if she was
seeing him in her panic Maisie
she was running pell-mell toward his
cage running as fast as she could manage
which given her bulk was really no
faster than a brisk walk Eli couldn't
understand why she was naked or why she
was running or why she was covered in
blood and where was everyone for [ __ ]
sake and he opened his mouth to ask her
these things to bring some clarity to
the chaos but then his eyes flicked
upward seeing beyond her and he knew a
woman tall and wisp liked thick red hair
falling in natural waves around a
flawless pale face step down from the
door freddy's trailer moving languidly
gracefully as if she had all the time in
the world
her eerie slowness contrasted sharply
with Maisie's frenzied waddling and the
sight could have been funny if Eli had
been sufficiently cold-hearted to
appreciate the humor the woman came
closer seeming to glide over the ground
her lips red and glinting wet in the
moonlight Eli Maisie was mere feet from
his cage her pendulous breasts slapping
pudgy hands beseeching she came for
Freddy I was trying to get the keys she
was babbling hysterical an Eli wasn't
sure if he knew exactly what she meant
who was the woman she was one of his
kind of course he could tell that by
looking at her but what was she doing
here what did she want with Freddy or
with Maisie
Eli knelt down to bring himself face to
face with the fat lady she was terrified
but somehow sublime in her terror how
her blood would taste now spiked with
the spice of adrenaline he put the
thought from his mind I didn't get the
keys she was saying barely able to talk
through her panting breaths
she killed Freddy and I couldn't find
them
the woman had closed the distance
between herself and her quarry with
superhuman speed an eel I could now see
the hard cold lines of her beauty the
sharp upturned angles of jaw and brow so
unlike Maisie's soft curves and round
cheeks she killed Freddie
the fat lady gasped again clutching the
bars in her hands
eli reached out and brushed her finger
with his thinking of her beautiful
wrists bruised violet mere inches from
his questing mouth no escape no not
tonight
but her flesh was there before him he
could smell it almost taste it's a
rousing tang of fear the vampire woman
appeared behind Mazie her flint black
eyes fixed on eli take a look at you she
said her voice like diamonds encased in
velvet how pathetic you are who are you
his hand still stroked Maisie's and the
contact seemed to have calmed her a bit
a friend the imperious woman replied
contempt radiating off her shimmering
skin our little community heard of your
capture and subsequent degradation we've
been tracking you for weeks
mazie was crying softly but she kept
still and why would you do that
eli asked why is my situation any
business of yours she arched an eyebrow
at him the fate of any one of our kind
is my business she said I thought you
would be pleased to see that you had not
been abandoned or am I to assume you
enjoy being paraded before slack-jawed
vermin like a performing dog eli squared
his shoulders I'm capable of looking
after myself so I see her bloody lips
curled upward in an icy parody of a
smile but you put too much faith in
these useless sacks of flesh my brother
this one told you herself that she was
unable to attain the means for your
escape did she not the woman ran a long
finger nail down Mazie spine and the fat
lady shuddered and closed her eyes tears
spilling from between the lashes leave
her be
Eli said with less authority than he'd
hoped or what you'll leap through those
bars and tear out my heart you know I
can't do that
can't you well that I suppose I can do
as I please
the woman lowered her head and extended
her long red tongue drawing it along
Maisie's bare shoulder with languorous
ecstasy oh she's delectable the woman
mewed I know you've taken a few poultry
samples but don't you think it's time to
feast she's trembling under my hands
brother the fear will make her taste of
heaven eli breathes raggedly torn
between desires the scent of Maisie's
blood was a heady narcotic making him
stupid with hunger and longing but her
terror also inspired pity something he
had never felt toward a human not ever
in his long life the cocktail of
emotions made him feel faint and ill
shall I release you myself
the woman asked her hands were vise
tight around Maisie's upper arms there's
enough of her for us to share afterwards
you may come back to your own people
with me Eli couldn't help himself
how could you release me the bars she
laughed a coal-black sound Eli noticed
that all the crickets and night birds
had fallen silent you're more of a rubes
and the imbeciles who come to gawk at
you she spent garlic and crosses how
could such things possibly harm
creatures such as way my hands burned
whenever I touched them
Eli held up his flayed palms as evidence
only because you believe they will she
said her arm shot forward white fingers
wrapping around a bar no hiss of frying
flesh no stink no smoke she smiled again
you see Maisie had quieted still fearful
but now watching their exchange with
obvious interest Eli she breathed her
voice thick with phlegm this means you
could have got out any time I didn't
even need to steal the keys no Maisie
Eli's head was spinning the lights in
the trailers were still glowing and he
imagined the faces of the carnies and
the freaks pressed against the glass
staring at the drama unfolding this
woman she's more powerful than I am I
couldn't have
eli is that your name the woman had
regained her iron grip on the fat lady's
arms and squeeze hard so that Maisie
yelped like a kicked puppy well Eli I
see that you've taken quite a shine to
this aberration of humanity I'll tell
you what we'll do if you can free
yourself from that cage and frankly that
is a laughably easy task for a being
such as yourself then I will let your
repulsive lady friend live however if
you cannot the woman bared her teeth
twin rows of needles carved from
mother-of-pearl Maisie met his gaze her
eyes no longer dancing but pleading her
cheeks were red and blotchy her nose
crusted with mucus Eli's shaking hands
raised as if on threads and he reached
for the bars the strands of dried garlic
twined like deadly blossoms the crosses
were stark and white against the black
metal he flashed back to the burning the
flaying of his flesh at the touch of the
tainted cage did he believe her she had
touched the bars with no injury but
perhaps she was older in possession of
powers that Eli could only dream of his
fingers hovered near the bars the only
sounds were Macy's hitching breaths the
pad of his index finger made contact for
a moment he felt the heat the promise of
pain but then it was gone it was only
metal nothing more his fists closed over
the crosses brushed the garlic bulbs he
felt a vibration through his bones
almost as though the bars were an
extension of him as if in conquering
them he had internalized them drawing
his strength the power nesting within
him that was fed on the gift of Macy's
blood he parted the bars as easily as
pulling aside a curtain he could have
laughed but then a thought sobered him I
could have escaped anytime Oh Maisie I'm
so sorry Eli left to the ground he felt
like howling like spinning madly in
circles in the dust he could run and
stalk and kill again by the light of the
stars he could suck the night air into
his lungs a free man
a snuffling firm AZ brought him back to
the situation at hand the vampire woman
had practically climbed onto Macy's
broad back perching there like a sleek
and beautiful vulture very good Eli
she said her perfect hands caressing the
Fat Lady's breasts and stomach with
lascivious abandon I told you you could
do it if you wanted it enough
she smiled wide her teeth glistening
then tipped her head in a curious
gesture like a songbird scanning the
grass for worms it will be dawn soon she
said you should feed before going to
ground
Eli took a step toward her I know I made
a bargain the woman was saying now her
hands moving lazily over Macy's bloodied
flab through her golden curls but I'm so
hungry Eli that circus master was
practically all dried up to tell you the
truth hardly worth eating
her eyes glittered she began to move no
Eli jumped at her but before he could
get there before he could stop her the
woman had reared back her head and then
bent sharply forward plunging her teeth
into the yielding skin at the juncture
between Macy's neck and shoulder the fat
lady gave a high gobbling cry and Eli
rushed for her several scarlet rivers
burst from their source at her throat
like red waters breaking a dam Maisy's
eyes watched Eli's as the life pumped
out of her and he could have cried at
what he read there he wanted to take her
hands to crush her massive body to him
to feel her heart beating in the space
between them but her eyes were already
starting to dull her knees to crumple
beneath her weight
the woman tore and gulped savage and
ugly and her hunger before Maisie fell
before her curls stopped bobbing forever
she parted her lips seemingly to take
her last breath but no Eli realized as
he leaned over her the lips were forming
words Eli she said her voice like a
winter wind through reeds it's all right
honey she was on the ground now her body
a tangle of limbs and fat topped with
bloody dribbles the woman tearing at her
shoulder no longer seemed of any concern
to her
Eli Macey said again murmuring his name
like a prayer finish me her head nodded
and Eli thought she was gone but then
she raised her chin stubbornly her eyes
were half closed and sleepy drink me dry
Drac she whispered and then astoundingly
she smiled you'll be stronger then
strong and free
she tried to lift a hand to touch his
face but she could not her shoulders
sagged Oh Maisie thought Eli he could
have loved her if circumstances had been
different she had been so giving so
generous he didn't think he would ever
meet her like again if he lived for
thousands of years and searched through
all the corners of the world the
thoughts saddened him but only for a
moment for her selflessness her
uniqueness will that made her life all
the more precious did it not with the
strength and confidence bestowed on him
by his wonderful and giving fat lady he
knocked the vampire woman into the dirt
and knelt at Maci's shoulder to taste
just how precious she was
it is probable that everybody who is at
all a constant dreamer has had at least
one experience of an event or a sequence
of circumstances which have come to his
mind and sleep being subsequently
realized in the material world but in my
opinion so far from this being a strange
thing it would be far aughter if this
fulfillment did not occasionally happen
since our dreams are as a rule concerned
with people whom we know and places with
which we are familiar such as might very
naturally occur in the awake and day lit
world true these dreams are often broken
into by some absurd and fantastic
incident which puts them out of court in
regard to their subsequent fulfillment
but on the mere calculation of chances
it does not appear in the least unlikely
that a dream imagined by anyone who
dreams constantly should occasionally
come true not long ago for instance I
experienced such a fulfillment of a
dream which seems to me in no way
remarkable and to have no kind of
psychical significance the manner of it
was as follows a certain friend of mine
living abroad is amiable enough to write
to me about once in a fortnight thus
when fourteen days or thereabouts have
elapsed since I last heard from him my
mind probably either consciously or
subconsciously is expectant of a letter
from him one night last week I dreamed
that as I was going upstairs to dress
for dinner I heard as I often did the
sound of the postman's knock on my front
door and diverted my direction
downstairs instead there among other
correspondence was a letter from him
thereafter the fantastic entered for on
opening it I found inside the ace of
diamonds and scribbled across it in his
well-known handwriting I am sending you
this for safe custody as you know it is
running an unreasonable risk to keep
aces in Italy
the next evening I was just preparing to
go upstairs to dress when I heard the
postman's knock and did precisely as I
had done in my dream there among other
letters was one from my friend only it
did not contain the ace of diamonds had
it done so I should have attached more
weight to the matter which as it stands
seems to me a perfectly ordinary
coincidence no doubt I consciously or
subconsciously expected a letter from
him and this suggested to me my dream
similarly the fact that my friend had
not written to me for a fortnight
suggested to him that he should do so
but occasionally it is not so easy to
find such an explanation and for the
following story I can find no
explanation at all it came out of the
dark and into the dark it has gone again
all my life I have been a habitual
dreamer the Knights are few that is to
say when I do not find on awaking in the
morning that some mental experience has
been mine and sometimes all night long
apparently a series of the most dazzling
adventures befall me almost without
exception these adventures are pleasant
though often merely trivial it is of an
exception that I am going to speak it
was when I was about sixteen that a
certain dream first came to me and this
is how it befell it opened with my being
set down at the door of a big red brick
house where I understood I was going to
stay the servant who opened the door
told me that tea was being served in the
garden and led me through a low dark
paneled hall with a large open fireplace
onto a cheerful green lawn set round
with flowerbeds there were grouped about
the tea table a small party of people
but they were all strangers to me except
one who was a school fellow called Jack
stone clearly the son of the house and
he introduced me to his mother and
father and a couple of sisters I was I
remember somewhat astonished to find
myself here for the boy in question was
scarcely known to me and I rather
disliked what I knew of him moreover he
had left school nearly a year before
the afternoon was very hot and an
intolerable oppression rained on the far
side of the lawn ran a red brick wall
with an iron gate in its centre outside
which stood a walnut tree we sat in the
shadow of the house opposite a row of
long windows inside which I could see a
table with cloth laid glimmering with
glass and silver this guard in front of
the house was very long and at one end
of it stood a tower of three stories
which looked to me much older than the
rest of the building before long mrs.
stone who like the rest of the party had
sat in absolute silence
said to me jack will show you to your
room I have given you the room in the
tower quite inexplicably my heart sank
at her words I felt as if I had known
that I should have got the room in the
tower and that it contained something
dreadful and significant Jack instantly
got up and I understood that I had to
follow him in silence we passed through
the hall and mounted a great oak
staircase with many corners and arrived
at a small landing with two doors set in
it he pushed one of these open for me to
enter and without coming in himself
closed it after me then I knew that my
conjecture had been right there was
something awful in the room and with the
terror of Nightmare growing swiftly and
enveloping me I awoke in a spasm of
terror now that dream are variations on
it occurred to me intermittently for
fifteen years
most often it came in exactly this form
the arrival the tea laid out on the lawn
the deadly silence succeeded by that one
deadly sentence the mounting with Jack
stone up to the room in the tower were
horror dwelt and it always came to a
close in the nightmare of Terror at that
which was in the room though I never saw
what it was and other times I
experienced variations on the same theme
occasionally for instance we would be
sitting at dinner in the dining room
into the windows of which I had looked
on the first night when the dream of
this house visited me but wherever we
were there was the same silence the same
sense of dreadful oppression and
foreboding
and the silence I knew would always be
broken by mrs. stone saying to me jack
will show you to your room I have given
you the room in the tower upon which
this was invariable I had to follow him
up the oak staircase with many corners
and enter the place that I dreaded more
and more each time that I visited it and
sleep or again I would find myself
playing cards still in silence in a
drawing-room lit with immense
chandeliers that gave a blinding
illumination what the game was I have no
idea what I remember with a sense of
miserable anticipation was that soon
mrs. stone would get up and say to me
jack will show you to your room I have
given you the room in the tower this
drawing-room where we played cards was
next to the dining room and as I have
said was always brilliantly illuminated
whereas the rest of the house was full
of dusk and shadows and yet how often in
spite of those bouquets of lights
have I not pored over the cards that
were dealt me scarcely able for some
reason to see them their designs too
were strange there were no red suits but
all were black and among them there were
certain cards which were black all over
I hated and dreaded those as this dream
continued to recur I got to know the
greater part of the house it was a
smoking room beyond the drawing-room at
the end of the passage with a green
baize door it was always very dark there
and as often as I went there I passed
somebody whom I could not see in the
doorway coming out curious developments
to took place in the characters that
people the dream as might happen to
living persons mrs. stone for instance
who when I first saw her had been
black-haired became grey and instead of
rising briskly as she had done at first
when she said Jack will show you to your
room I've given you the room in the
tower got up very feebly as if the
strength was leaving her limbs Jack also
grew up and became a rather ill looking
young man with a brown mustache while
one of the sisters ceased to appear and
I understood she was married then it so
happened that I was not visited by this
dream for six months or more and I began
to hope in such an explicable dread did
I hold it that it had passed away for
good
but one night after this interval I
again found myself being shown out onto
the lawn for tea and mrs. stone was not
there while the others were all dressed
in black at once I guessed the reason
and my heart leaped at the thought that
perhaps this time I should not have to
sleep in the room in the tower and
though we usually all sat in silence on
this occasion the sense of relief made
me talk and laugh as I had never yet
done
but even then matters were not
altogether comfortable for no one else
spoke but they all looked secretly at
each other and soon the foolish stream
of my talk ran dry and gradually an
apprehension worse than anything I had
previously known gained on me as the
light slowly faded suddenly a voice
which I knew well broke the stillness
the voice of mrs. stone saying jack will
show you to your room I have given you
the room in the tower it seemed to come
from near the gate in the red brick wall
that bounded the lawn and looking up I
saw that the grass outside was sewn
thick with gravestones a curious grayish
light shone from them and I could read
the lettering on the grave nearest me
and it was in evil memory of Julius
Stone and as usual Jack got up and again
I followed him through the hall and up
the staircase with many corners on this
occasion it was darker than usual and
when I passed into the room in the tower
I could only just see the furniture the
position of which was already familiar
to me
also there was a dreadful odor of decay
in the room and I woke screaming the
dream with such variations and
developments as I have mentioned went on
at intervals for 15 years sometimes I
would dream it two or three nights in
succession once as I have said there was
an intermission of six months but taking
a reasonable average I should say that I
dreamed it quite as often as once in a
month it had as his planes something of
Nightmare about it since it always ended
in the same appalling terror which so
far from getting less seemed to me to
gather fresh fear every time that I
experienced it there was to a strange
and dreadful consistency about it the
characters in it as I have mentioned got
regularly older death and marriage
visited this silent family and I never
in the dream after mrs.
died set eyes on her again but it was
always her voice that told me that the
room in the tower was prepared for me
and whether we had tea out on the lawn
or the scene was laid in one of the
rooms overlooking it I could always see
her gravestone standing just outside the
iron gate it was the same two with a
married daughter usually she was not
present but once or twice she returned
again and company with a man whom I took
to be her husband he too like the rest
of them was always silent but owing to
the constant repetition of the dream I
had ceased to attach in my waking hours
any significance to it I never met Jack
stone again during all those years nor
did I ever see a house that resembled
this dark house of my dream and then
something happened I had been in London
in this year up until the end of July
and during the first week in August went
down to stay with a friend in the house
he had taken for the summer months in
the Ashdown Forest District of Sussex I
left London early for John Clinton was
to meet me at Forest Row Station and we
were going to spend the day golfing and
go to his house in the evening he had
his motorcar with him and we set off
about five of the afternoon after a
thoroughly delightful day for the drive
the distance being some ten miles as it
was so early we did not have tea at the
clubhouse but waited till we should get
home as we drove the weather which up
till then had been though hot
deliciously fresh seemed to me to alter
in quality and become very stagnant and
oppressive and I felt that indefinable
sense of ominous apprehension that I am
accustomed to before Thunder John
however did not share my views
attributing my loss of lightness to the
fact that I had lost both my matches
events proved however that I was right
though I do not think that the
thunderstorm that broke that night was
the sole cause of my depression our way
lay through deep high banked lanes and
before we had gone very far I fell
asleep and was only awakened by the
stopping of the motor and with a sudden
thrill partly a fear but chiefly of
curiosity I found myself standing in the
doorway of the house of my dream we went
I half wondering whether or not I was
dreaming still through a low oak paneled
Hall and out onto the lawn where tea was
laid in the shadow of the house
it was set in flower beds a red brick
wall with a gate in it bounded on one
side and out beyond that was a space of
rough grass with a walnut tree the
facade of the house was very long and at
one end stood a three-story Tower
markedly older than the rest here for
the moment
all resemblance to the repeated dream
ceased there was no silent and somehow
terrible family but a large assembly of
exceedingly cheerful persons all of whom
were known to me and in spite of the
horror with which the dream itself had
always filled me I felt nothing of it
now that the scene of it was thus
reproduced before me but I felt intense
as curiosity as to what was going to
happen T pursued its cheerful course and
before long mrs. Clinton had got up and
at that moment I think I knew what she
was going to say she spoke to me and
what she said was Jack will show you to
your room I have given you the room in
the tower at that for half a second the
horror of the dream took hold of me
again but it quickly passed and again I
felt nothing more than the most intense
curiosity it was not very long before it
was amply satisfied John turned to me
right up at the top of the house he said
but I think you'll be comfortable we're
absolutely full up would you like to go
and see it now by Jove I believe that
you're right and we are going to have a
thunderstorm how dark it's become I got
up and followed him we passed through
the hall and up the perfectly familiar
staircase then he opened the door and I
went in and at that moment she run
reasoning terror again possessed me I
did not know what I feared I simply
feared then like a sudden recollection
when one remembers a name which has long
escaped the memory I knew what I feared
I feared mrs. stone whose grave with the
sinister inscription in evil memory I
had so often seen in my dream just
beyond the lawn which lay below my
window and then once more the fear
passed so completely that I wondered
what there was to fear and I found
myself sober and quiet and sane in the
room in the tower the name of which I
had so often heard in my dream and the
scene of which was so familiar
I looked around it with a certain sense
of proprietorship and found that nothing
had been changed from the Dreaming
nights in which I knew it so well
just to the left of the door was the bed
lengthways along the wall with the head
of it in the angle in a line with it was
the fireplace and a small bookcase
opposite the door the outer wall was
pierced by two lattice paned windows
between which stood the dressing table
while ranged along the fourth wall was
the washing stand and a big cupboard my
luggage had already been unpacked for
the furniture of dressing and undressing
lay orderly on the wash stand and toilet
table while my dinner clothes were
spread out on the coverlet of the bed
and then with a sudden start of
unexplained dismay I saw that there were
two rather conspicuous objects which I
had not seen before in my dreams one a
life-sized oil painting of mrs. stone
the other a black-and-white sketch of
Jack stone representing him as he had
appeared to me only a week before in the
last of the series of these repeated
dreams a rather secret and evil-looking
man of about thirty his picture hung
between the windows looking straight
across the room to the other portrait
which hung at the side of the bed at
that I looked next and as I looked I
felt once more the horror of the
nightmare seized me it represented mrs.
stone as I had seen her last in my
dreams old and withered and white-haired
but in spite of the evident feebleness
of body a dreadful exuberance and
vitality shone through the envelope of
flesh an exuberance wholly malign a
vitality that foamed and frost with
unimaginable evil evil beamed from the
narrow leering eyes it laughed in the
demon-like mouth the whole face was
instinct with some secret and appalling
mirth the hands clasped together on the
knee seemed shaking with suppressed and
nameless glee then I saw also that it
was signed in the left hand bottom
corner and wondering who the artist
could be I looked more closely and read
the inscription
Julia stone by Julia Stone there came a
tap at the door and John Clinton entered
got everything you want he asked rather
more than I want said I pointing to the
picture he laughed hard-featured old
lady he said by herself too I remember
anyhow she can't flatter herself much
but don't you see said I it's scarcely a
human face at all it's the face of some
witch of some devil he looked at it more
closely yes it isn't very pleasant he
said scarcely a bedside manner eh yes I
can imagine getting the nightmare if I
went to sleep with that clothes by my
bed I'll have it taken down if you like
I really wish you would I said he rang
the bell and with the help of a servant
we'd attached the picture and carried it
out onto the landing and put it with its
face to the wall
by Jove the old ladies await said John
mopping his forehead I wonder if she had
something on her mind the extraordinary
weight of the picture had struck me too
I was about to reply when I caught sight
of my own hand there was blood on it in
considerable quantities covering the
whole palm I've cut myself somehow said
I John gave a little startled
exclamation why I have to he said
simultaneously the footman took out his
handkerchief and wiped his hand with it
I saw that there was blood also on his
handkerchief John and I went back into
the tower room and washed the blood off
but neither on his hand nor on mine was
there the slightest trace of a scratch
or cut it seemed to me that having
ascertained this we both by a sort of
tacit consent did not allude to it again
something in my case had dimly occurred
to me that I did not wish to think about
it was but a conjecture but I fancied
that I knew the same thing had occurred
to him the heat and oppression of the
air for the storm we'd expected was
still undestand for some time most of
the party among whom were John Clinton
and myself sat outside on the path
bounding the lawn where we had had tea
the night was absolutely dark and no
twinkle of star moon ray could penetrate
the pall of cloud that over set the sky
by degrees our assembly thinned the
women went up to bed men dispersed to
the smoking or billiard room and by
eleven o'clock my host and I were the
only two left all the evening I thought
that he had something on his mind and as
soon as we were alone he spoke
the man who helped us with the picture
had blood on his hand too did you notice
he said I asked him just now if he had
cut himself and he said he supposed he
had but that he could find a mark of it
now where did that blood come from by
dint of telling myself that I was not
going to think about it I had succeeded
in not doing so and I did not want
especially just a bedtime to be reminded
of it I don't know said I and I don't
really care so long as the picture of
mrs. stone is not by my bed he got up
but it's odd he said ha
now you'll see another odd thing a dog
of his an Irish Terrier by breed had
come out of the house as we talked the
door behind us into the hall was open
and a bright oblong of light shone
across the lawn to the iron gate which
led on to the rough grass outside where
the walnut tree stood I saw that the dog
had all his hackles up bristling with
rage and fright his lips were curled
back from his teeth as if he was ready
to spring at something and he was
growling to himself he took not the
slightest notice of his master or me but
stiffly intensely walked across the
grass to the iron gate there he stood
for a moment looking through the bars
and still growling then of a sudden his
courage seemed to desert him he gave one
long howl and scuttled back to the house
with a curious crouching sort of
movement he does that half a dozen times
a day said John he sees something which
he both hates and fears I walked to the
gate and looked over it something was
moving on the grass outside and soon a
sound which I could not instantly
identify came to my ears then I
remembered what it was it was the
purring of a cat I lit a match and saw
the parure
a big blue Persian walking round and
round in a little circle just outside
the gate stepping high and ecstatically
with tail carried aloft like a banner
its eyes were bright and shining and
every now and then it put its head down
and sniffed at the grass I laughed the
end of that mystery I'm afraid I said
here's a large cat having vol purga
Snite all alone yes that's darius said
john he spends half the day at all night
there but that's not the end of the dog
mystery for Toby and he are the best of
friends but the beginning of the cat
mystery what's the cat doing there and
why is dari is pleased while toby is
terror-stricken
at that moment I remembered the rather
horrible detail of my dreams when I saw
through the gate where the cat was now
the white tombstone with the sinister
inscription but before I could answer
the rain began as suddenly and heavily
as if a tap had been turned on and
simultaneously the big cat squeezed
through the bars the gate and came
leaping across the lawn to the house for
shelter then it sat in the doorway
looking out eagerly into the dark its
spat and struck at John with its paw as
he pushed it in in order to close the
door somehow with the portrait of Julius
Stone in the passage outside the room in
the tower had absolutely no alarm for me
and as I went to bed feeling very sleepy
and heavy
I had nothing more than interest for the
Curious Incident about our bleeding
hands and the conduct of the cat and dog
the last thing I looked at before I put
out my light was the square empty space
by my bed where the portrait had been
here the paper was of its original full
tint of dark red over the rest of the
walls that had faded then I blew out my
candle and instantly fell asleep my
awaking was equally instantaneous and I
sat bolt upright in bed under the
impression that some bright light had
been flashed in my face though it was
now absolutely pitch dark I knew exactly
where I was in the room which I had read
it in dreams but no horror that I ever
felt when asleep approached the fear
that now invaded and froze my brain
immediately after a peal of Thunder
crackled just above the house but the
probability that it was only a flash of
lightning which awoke me gave no
reassurance to my galloping heart
something I knew was in the room with me
and instinctively I put out my right
hand which was nearest the wall to keep
it away and my hand touched the edge of
a picture frame hanging close to me I
sprang out of bed upsetting the small
table that stood by it and I heard my
watch candle and matches clatter onto
the floor but for the moment there was
no need of light for a blinding flash
leaped out of the clouds and showed me
that by my bed again hung the picture of
mrs. stone and instantly the room went
into blackness again but in that flash I
saw another thing also namely a figure
that leaned over the end of my bed
watching me
it was dressed in some clothes clinging
white garment spotted and stained with
mould and the face was that of the
portrait
overhead the Thunder cracked and roared
and when it ceased and the deathly
stillness succeeded I heard the rustle
of movement coming nearer me and more
horrible yet perceived an odor of
corruption and decay and then a hand was
laid on the side of my neck and close
beside my ear I heard quick taken eager
breathing yet I knew that this thing
though it could be perceived by touch by
smell by eye and by ear was still not of
this earth but something that had passed
out of the body and had power to make
itself manifest then a voice already
familiar to me spoke I knew you would
come to the room in the tower it said I
have long been waiting for you at last
you have come tonight I shall feast
before long we will feast together and
the quick breathing came closer to me I
could feel it on my neck at that the
terror which I think had paralyzed me
for a moment
gave way to the wild instinct of
self-preservation I hid wildly with both
arms kicking out at the same moment and
heard a little animal squeal and
something soft dropped with a thud
beside me I took a couple of steps
forward nearly tripping up over whatever
it was that lay there and by the merest
good luck found the handle of the door
in another second I ran out on the
landing and it banged the door behind me
almost at the same moment I heard a door
open somewhere below and John Clinton
candalyn hand came running upstairs what
is it he said I sleep just below you and
heard a noise as if good heavens there's
blood on your shoulder I stood there so
he told me afterwards swaying from side
to side white as a sheet with a mark on
my shoulder as if a hand covered with
blood had been laid there it's in there
I said pointing she you know the
portrait is in there too hanging up on
the place we took it from at that he
laughed My dear fellow this is mere
nightmare he said he pushed by me and
opened the door i standing there simply
an irk with terror unable to stop him
unable to move what an awful smell he
said then there was silence he had
passed out of my sight behind the open
door
next moment he came out again as white
as myself and instantly shut it yes the
portraits there he said and on the floor
is a thing a thing spotted with earth
like what they bury people in come away
quick come away how I got downstairs I
hardly know an awful shuddering and
nausea of the spirit rather than of the
flesh had seized me and more than once
he had to place my feet upon the steps
while every now and then he cast glances
of terror and apprehension up the stairs
but in time we came to his dressing room
on the floor below and there I told him
what I have here described the sequel
can be made short indeed some of my
readers have perhaps already guessed
what it was if they remember that
inexplicable affair of the churchyard at
West folly some eight years ago where an
attempt was made three times to bury the
body of a certain woman who had
committed suicide on each occasion the
coffin was found in the course of a few
days again protruding from the ground
after the third attempt in order that
the thing should not be talked about the
body was buried elsewhere in
unconsecrated ground where it was buried
was just outside the iron gate of the
garden belonging to the house where this
woman had lived she had committed
suicide in a room at the top of the
tower in that house her name was Julius
Stone subsequently the body was again
secretly dug up and the coffin was found
to be full of blood